you are watching the press preview first
look at what's on the front pages as
they arrive so it's time to see what's
making the headlines we're the director
of the john smith center at the
university of glasgow kezia dugdale and
the conservative commentator tim
montgomery they'll be with us from now
until just before midnight
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now
the metro has spoken to public transport
workers who say that although mosques
are still mandatory on their services
too many passengers are simply ignoring
the rules
the telegraph hears from dame sarah
gilbert who led the development of the
oxford astrazeneca vaccine she says
worldwide distribution should be a
greater priority than booster jabs
but the times reports booster jabs could
get the green light next week alleging a
covert 19 vaccine top up leads to a rise
in protection
scrapping the benefits uplift will hit
the sickest areas hardest that's
according to the guardian
whereas the daily mail leads with the
consequences of remote gps as doctors
say phone and video appointments are
here to stay
the financial times reports that the
european central bank is starting to
ease its emergency bond buying program
as the eurozone economy shows signs of
recovery
well i'm joined tonight by kezia dugdale
and tim montgomery welcome to you both
good evening
let's start off by having a look at the
telegraph uh and that story that there's
a suggestion that boosters might not
necessarily be
the priority um this is according to the
scientists who led the oxford uh jab
kezia
yeah so the headline here is a little
misleading because she's not condemning
the idea of mass boosters by any stretch
of the imagination she's just arguing
that if we have excess vaccine supply it
might be a lot smarter to give that to
other countries around the world whose
vaccination rates are far far smaller
than ours not just as a good deed or you
know some sort of moral duty but because
getting other countries to increase
their vaccination levels is a way that
we can protect ourselves from an
increase in new variant you know if
another new variant was to come along
that defied the current vaccines that we
have we could be right back to square
one again when it comes to covert so
this is her advice today saying yes give
those who are immuno suppressed a third
jab
beyond that point let's give those jabs
to other countries to protect ourselves
against any future variant
but tim doesn't it raise doubts though
about the effectiveness of a third jab
if she's suggesting that
we needn't go for it straight away
yes and i think anyone who takes at
least a superficial look at the times
front page that you just mentioned
jillian and the telegraph story will be
concerned as to whether scientists
really agree on the value of a uh
booster jab i think kez and i might even
agree on the subtext though of um this
uh telegraph piece and that's really you
know we are potentially embarking upon a
third jab for the average british
citizen when most of the vulnerable
people in the developing world haven't
he even had a first vaccination and i
think that's probably the primary thing
we should take away
from dame sarah gilbert's um point is
that if we don't vaccinate the
developing world we will get um more
variants of covid but what we used to
call the indian variant now the delta
variant because and the kovid as we've
begun to learn fries in areas where
vaccination rates are incredibly low so
in terms of priorities i would love to
see not just britain but the advanced
western world just be a little bit more
generous to a lot more generous to the
developing world because actually if
we're serious about protecting ourselves
then we should do an awful lot more to
protect some of the most vulnerable
people on the planet there are mixed
messages though aren't there because the
telegraph and the times are at odds with
the the times telling us that
booster vaccines are expected perhaps as
early as next week to to get the go
ahead so a completely different message
to to the one of of caution
in the daily telegraph kesia
these are really nuanced arguments of
course there's you know a small margin
of error between what's the right thing
to do and what's not here and you know
sarah gilbert is not saying let's not do
it she's just saying a better use of
these jabs would be to use them overseas
and it's not the first time she said
something a little against the grain of
what you feel like is going to be the
government's direction because of course
she's already spoken out about the idea
of vaccinating children we've got the
jcvi saying that the case for
vaccinating teenagers in particular is
marginal and sarah gilbert said it's
probably not worth doing it at all now
that is a very refined medical clinical
take on on the effectiveness of
vaccinations on young people what it
perhaps doesn't factor in is the wider
societal benefits people see vaccinating
children like for example making sure
they don't miss so much of school that
leads to deteriorating mental health or
negative outcomes when it comes to
educational opportunities so that's why
the science isn't always clear-cut
because we're not always asking the
scientists very explicit questions about
whether it's just a clinical question
about the effectiveness of our vaccine
or whether it's about it's the best
thing to do in the context of a pandemic
and it's long-term impacts on the way
that society is functioning
and uh tim do you think we might see
people uh holding back from taking the
the booster jab because of of headlines
that we've precisely seen in in the
telegraph
i do i do and actually you know there's
this whole debate about vaccine
passports that we might come on to if we
have time but i think there is some
early evidence that when you um
introduce the idea of compulsion uh for
vaccines there are certainly a group of
people who already vaccine skeptical who
actually become more skeptical they
think well if they're compelling us to
take this vaccine they really do have
something to hide and what this vaccine
may be in terms of safety so i think we
do need to proceed cautiously and i
think there's an element just as we've
been having this discussion about what
exactly is the value the relative value
of booster vaccines i think there's been
occasions during this whole kobe debate
when scientists have perhaps in a bid to
reassure us have actually failed to
reassure us by being more definite than
the science often um would suggest and i
think taking the public more into
the scientists confidence
setting out the pros and cons and
letting all of us make informed
decisions rather than
overstating what is what they know
probably in the long run will build more
public confidence in a medical strategy
to defeat this virus that's upturned all
our lives over the last 18 months uh and
kezia on the same subject we read in the
guardian that um apparently reportedly
ministers of piled pressure on the
vaccines watchdog to approve a
large-scale program of booster jabs and
this um as the number of people in
hospital with the virus has exceeded
eight thousand and that's the first time
since march
yes i mean there's there's no doubt that
rates are spiraling and when they spiral
slowdowns the risk we see this in
scotland already because of course our
schools have gone back earlier than the
english schools and also we've got a few
universities that are starting their
freshers week this week so we're a
little bit ahead of that curve and as a
result we're seeing rates rise in
scotland so that is what winter is going
to look like it is spiraling rate of
covid and of course the higher
the number of people with the infections
the greater the impact that has on the
nhs if boosters can be a part of
reducing the pressure on the nhs then
the government will be very very keen to
see those in place but it's a finely
tuned balance once again because in the
papers that we're looking at here
there's a suggestion that yes vulnerable
people should get a booster but don't
give it to them too soon or it won't
last the length of the winter so we're
asking people to gear up for a third jab
but getting that jab has to arrive at
almost exactly the right point for it to
be as effective as the government needs
it to be
we stay on the theme of mixed messages
and have a look now at the um
metro
and this story is about commuters and
mask wearing that some people are not
wearing their masks and it's leading to
to rows and confrontations and even
uglier scenes on on public transport tim
well i have a confession jillian to make
uh to you and your viewers today i was
on a on a train to london and got into i
just forgot to put my mask on and it was
um an occasion when actually it's one of
the few times that um i've actually had
to sit next to anyone on the train for
18 months which is a good sign in a way
because the trains
are filling up and um immediately as i'm
the person who sat next to me said you
haven't got your mask on i put it on and
apologized but i think so long as the
rules are unclear and i think this is
the story that the metro is bringing out
i would of course been perfectly in my
rights if i was being in perhaps a
little bit discourteous to say i'm not
wearing a mask i don't have to but
actually i think it is a form of
courtesy we show to each other i'm not
entirely convinced about the value of
mass but i think it is something that
reassures other people it builds up
confidence as we all commute back to a
proper a way of life that we were
familiar with before this kovitz struck
and i think the ambiguity of rules with
different um transport authorities
different railways different underground
networks having different policies isn't
helping um the harmony that we would
like to see you think between all of us
as we as we as we go forward
cause you're shaking your head but i
mean if you don't say it's it's
mandatory for everyone to wear masks and
that instruction doesn't come from the
government then then you're going to
have this situation aren't you
i wasn't shaking my head because i
disagree with tim i was just going to
reflect on on the scottish position
because the rules are much stricter in
scotland you still have to wear masks on
trains as you do in shops and as you do
in enclosed spaces and so in that sense
the rules are very clear but
unfortunately and i feel really strongly
about this we still have lots of people
ignoring the advice in fact a lot to
wear a mask on trains in scotland and it
does my absolute dinner in because i
think you know for an individual to
choose not to wear a mask would be
acceptable if the impact of not wearing
that mask was born entirely by them and
them alone but it's not by not choosing
to wear a mask they are potentially
risking other citizens around them and
that's why i'm so angry about it because
it's the simplest thing to ask people to
do in order to get us all back on public
transport gets back into offices getting
back into that working environment i'll
be really um
outrageous and say in my anecdotal
experience jillian it's largely young
men that are not wearing masks on public
transport it's almost as if they think
it's a badge of pride that they're
they're almost invincible from this
pandemic that continues to affect our
daily lives and the reality is that they
might be invincible but the person
sitting next to them could be far more
vulnerable to a serious infection so i'd
like to see much stronger rules for
quite some time yet especially as cases
are rising but reinforcing mass it's a
small thing we can all do to protect
each other very quickly tim yes or no
would you like to see uh stricter rules
in england
there's a lot of yes or no jillian
because you know supposedly
london has a ban on uh a requirement to
wear masks i've been on the tube the
last couple of days i would say 20 25 of
people aren't wearing masks even though
they're supposed to i saw no enforcement
whatsoever i can understand if you're a
tube worker you don't want to have to
confront the young very difficult it's
very difficult that is the the issue the
enforcement welcome back to both of you
let's take a look at the guardian uh now
nara front cover story um looking at a
health foundation study which is saying
that the um
the universal credit uplift
the benefits um being scrapped will hit
the sickest areas the hardest and people
are going to suffer uh terribly
according to their research kezia
yes the headlines are a bit of an
oxymoron for me you know the idea that
they're revealing the ending the
benefits uplift will hit the sickest
poorest people and the worst is almost a
statement of the obvious that's the
reality of what would happen if you cut
the benefits bill but it's also what
every major children's and anti-poverty
charity has been saying for several
months now if not over a year and the
reality is this is going to be a real
headache for the conservatives if they
go ahead with making this cut because
it's going to hurt a lot of those red
wall seats that are now very clearly
blue for the conservatives in the north
of england i was really surprised
actually that the government didn't
announce that they were going to retain
this uplift when they did everything
they've done this week around the
national insurance height because again
that's going to hurt people on low
incomes considerably harder than it will
affect me at least in percentage terms
and if they'd learn anything about
labour's playbook around using national
insurance to provide funding for the nhs
they'll remember that when labor
national insurance in the 1990s and into
early 2000s they um also alongside it
massively increased the benefit support
for our children in particular the child
benefit in particular i thought the
sweet thing they could have done this
week in order to land that national
insurance increase a little better would
be to have retained this uplifting
universal credit sadly that's not what
they've chosen to do here
yes and the work and pensions minister
lady stedman scott told the house of
lords yesterday that her department had
carried out no formal assessment of the
impact of returning universal credit to
its pre-pandemic
level um tim could they have um retained
the the uplift
well i think they may well retain
um if not all of the uplift i think they
may retain part of it um the guardian
article that kez has just been
discussing
mentions that 50 conservative mps have
expressed their concern over the taking
away of what was you know admittedly
something that the government promised
was a temporary measure to help people
through the pandemic but i think people
need this money lots of families all
over this country have come to depend
upon this money we're living in a period
when all the goods in the supermarket
are going up in tesco this evening and
just all sorts of things that you notice
they're going up in price and to take
away money from people at this time is
going to be very difficult and amongst
those 50 conservative mps they're not
just you know the normal troublemakers
who always rebel against the government
you've got a whole range of former
conservative um
work and pension secretary including ian
duncan smith the former tory leader who
is the architect of universal credit so
if the government thought that they've
got away with getting through their
controversial ni tax hike this week i
think that's just
a very sort of storming a teacup
compared to what could happen in the
house of commons when this measure comes
forward for debate kezie we've only got
a few seconds for you to tell us about
the uh mac cartoon in the telegraph
oh well this is really tim's but it's a
running joke about gavin williamson's
inability to tell the difference between
two black sporting heroes so the the
joke here is that um
man united have bought or they think
they've bought uh marcus rashford but
have an actual fact got gavin williams
instead so
it's real funny there from matt as
always as always for a hundred million
as well